I've got a drew lock thought okay he is
the luckiest man on the face of the
earth look at the last two drafts and I
don't just mean drew lock in 2019 in the
second round look at what they have done
for drew lock let's say the last three
drafts Courtland Sutton Jerry Judy
Deshawn Hamilton in the slot Noah fan at
tight end and Phillip Lindsay out of
nowhere a thousand years for each of the
first two years and now you go and get a
low cost Melvin Gordon as the backup
it's incredible we haven't even talked
about KJ hammer John Elway told me the
great story about KJ hammer remember his
100 yard kickoff return for Penn State
against Michigan yeah Elway told me that
when the scouts were watching that right
after the season this is when they're
all in the same room the scouts are
watching it no way said hey that guy is
so fast
let's time him in the 40 when he gets
going so they timed him like from the 30
his own 30 to the opposing 40 ok they
got our opposing 30 they got a 40-yard
dash and he ran it in 3.9 three seconds
and hello I just said this guy is
incredible we got to get this guy and
what's so great about this is the Denver
Broncos looked at the Kansas City Chiefs
and said okay you got Tyree killed you
got Sammy Watkins you got McCole Hardman
will call you that and we'll raise you
KJ handler Jerry Judi Cortland Sutton
and Deshawn Hamilton and let's see who
wins now the only problem
Sherlock might not be Patrick mahomes so
we'll see know what he's not
I just tell you he's not Patrick my
Holmes but he is damn good and I think
he has a chance to be real special
Patrick Mahone special I don't know
about that I mean I think all three of
us would agree this is about as special
as we've ever seen come into the NFL
especially after only three years
the league but Locke has a chance to be
really special to Locke was a first
round talent last year my turn me say
this a million times probably sick of
hearing me say you know he just he got
he got doc because his team fell apart
his last year at Missouri and people
blamed him
so that was stupid but man the talent to
Peter's point around him right now is
scary good and hey to let me know where
they get a leg up on Kansas see a little
bit of course their offense is not going
to be hitting on all cylinders like
Kansas City it's gonna take a little
time but the talent is eye-opening just
like Kansas City and the Broncos got a
leg up as far as on the Chiefs as are
concerned their defense I mean the
Broncos defense is the real deal and
when you got Bradley Chubb coming back
in jerel Casey you better watch out and
you know to to what drew Locke is saying
to that's very real when he talks about
like not wanting to let John Elway down
I mean you guys know this when you're
around good people who have faith in you
you want to make sure you prove them
right you know I mean gosh and you know
Jon Gruden hey there was times where I
wanted to shove it up where the Sun
don't shine sometimes with my play and
be like hey eat that buddy talk some
more crap to me but really at the end of
the day I wanted to please him because I
knew he had faith in me you know hey we
work with Tony Dungy I want to be a good
person when I'm around Tony judging
because I know he's so good I don't want
to disappoint him so that's a very
moment a viewing room and say what's up
expletive deleted sorry you're right he
probably doesn't like me
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports